[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
Ausgabe von Tatort Deutschland mein Name
ist Mirko Casimir und bei mir ist Stefan
Netzband hallo Stefan hallo lieber Mirko
und ein herzliches Willkommen auch von
mir und heute gehen wir wieder mal ein
ganzes Stück zurück in die Vergangenheit
zu einem wirklich muss man sagen die
zarren und ungewöhnlichen Fall der liegt
jetzt mehr als 100 Jahre zurück und er
gilt als der erste Fall einer ganz neuen
Kategorie von morgen na ja ganz neu
damals aber inzwischen gibt es diese
Kategorie schon gar nicht mehr oder ja
vielleicht nicht in der Form sie hat
sich weiterentwickelt aber vielleicht
sollten wir ja mal aufhören in Rätseln
zu sprechen offene Rätsel gibt es später
übrigens noch genug es geht um eine
Serienmörderin das ist schon
ungewöhnlich genug denn Serienmorde sind
ja eigentlich eher so ein männer-ding na
ja ein paar Frauen mit entsprechenden
Ambitionen die hatten wir auch schon
hier im Podcast ne aber im Großen und
Ganzen hast du natürlich recht
heute geht es um belganes die um die
Wände vom 19 zum 20 Jahrhundert herum 20
möglicherweise sogar 40 Menschen
umgebracht haben soll sie wurde berühmt
als die erste
kontaktanzeigen-mörderin
Kontaktanzeigen also liebe junge
podcast-gemeinde Podcast HörerInnen
Kontaktanzeigen das war so eine Art
analog tinder für die die es nicht mehr
kennen furchtbar kompliziert und
langwierig Menschen gaben einen kleinen
Text in der Zeitung auf ohne Profilfoto
bloß eine kurze Selbstbeschreibung in
der gerne Wörter wie attraktiv sportlich
finanziell unabhängig und dergleichen
enthielten und dann wartete man
tatsächlich ob jemand per Brief darauf
antwortet dann schreibt man sich eine
Weile hin und her wobei natürlich immer
ein paar Tage vergangen sind von Antwort
zu Antwort und irgendwann traf man sich
dann schließlich wirklich und sah das
erste Mal sich in die Augen und fragte
sich was zum Teufel aus dieser Anzeige
so werden konnte das klang doch findest
du attraktiv und so weiter also man muss
sagen da ist dieses tinder wisch und weg
wie es nennen will natürlich wirklich
unkomplizierter naja aber ist einfach
mal so ist halt jetzt zumindest über ein
Jahrhundert lang war ziemlich gut
funktioniert ich meine Menschen haben
sich über sowas gefunden ja oder sie
hatten nach all diesen beschreibe
einfach keine Lust mehr weiter zu suchen
naja also spaß beiseite natürlich hat es
funktioniert Leute haben sich gesucht
und gefunden haben sich verliebt am
geheiratet haben Kinder bekommen und
haben einander ermordet ja damit sind
wir jetzt beim Fall belganes und Mirko
erzählt uns die Geschichte jetzt mal von
Anfang an belgernes wird am 11.11 1859
in Norwegen geboren
da trägt sie noch einen anderen Namen
sie heißt Brünhild Paul Starter storeset
und ich will jetzt hier nicht
respektierlich klingen aber Brünhild
passt irgendwie ein bisschen besser zu
ihr als Belle die schöne als junge Frau
ist sie um die 1,80 m groß sie ist
kräftig gebaut mit Farben maskulinen
Gesicht und naja lass es mich mal so
sagen also ich würde mich nicht mit ihr
auf eine Schlägerei einlassen den
Vornamen Bell gibt sie sich erst als sie
1881 mit 21 Jahren in die USA immigriert
um der Armut in ihrem Heimatland
Norwegen zu entkommen ja das war eine
andere Zeit in Norwegen heute ist das
Land das Land mit dem vierthöchsten
Durchschnittseinkommen der Welt fast
6000 € da wird glaube ich so schnell
heute keiner mehr auswandern naja außer
vielleicht nach Bermuda denn das ist
Platz Nummer eins mit einem
durchschnittlichen Einkommen von 8000 €
1881 war die USA jedenfalls der große
Traum die große Hoffnung die neue Welt
für Bell jedenfalls läuft alles gut sie
zieht nach Chicago zu ihrer Schwester
Nelly die den Sprung über den großen
Teich schon einige Jahre zuvor gewagt
hat
anfangs arbeitet sie als Dienstmädchen
dann findet sie einen Job in einer
Metzgerei und zerlegt Tierkadaver oha
also ich habe nichts gegen Metzger
einige meiner besten Freunde sind
Metzger aber im Ernst wenn man das im
Zusammenhang mit einer
serienmördergeschichte hört da klingeln
bei diesem Stichwort schon die
Alarmglocken naja jedenfalls 1884
heiratet sie Mats sohrensohn der genau
wie sie aus Norwegen stammt die beiden
bekommen vier Kinder und eröffnen 1896
ein Süßwarengeschäft in Chicago von der
Schlachterin zur bonbon-verkäuferin
weltversion des American Dream sie hatte
den laden die American cream nennen
können Stefan bitte ernst bleiben okay
jetzt sind wir nämlich auch schon an dem
Punkt wo aus dem Traum ein Albtraum wird
zwei ihrer Kinder sterben schon als
Babys die Sterbeurkunden geben bei
beiden eine Dickdarmentzündung als
Todesursache an der Tod von Kleinkindern
ist damals leider noch alltäglich und so
wird erst später auffallen dass die
Symptome unter denen die Kinder litten
vor allem Durchfall und Krämpfe auch
andere Ursachen gehabt haben könnten
eine Vergiftung nämlich
aber das ist Spekulation zum Glück im
Unglück sind die Kinder versichert
mit den Versicherungen werden wir
erfahren im Bell ist ganz genau oder ja
könnte man annehmen auch als 1897 der
Süßwarenladen und drei Jahre später das
Wohnhaus der Sohn sonst abbrennen
springen zum Glück die Versicherungen
ein und Zahlen ein Leben voll von
Schicksalsschlägen im Sommer 1900 stirbt
ihr Ehemann plötzlich und unerwartet an
einer Gehirnblutung oder einem
Herzinfarkt die Quellen widersprechen
sich da der einzige Trost für die Witwe
ihr Ehemann hat sich einen ganz
besonderen Tag für diesen plötzlichen
und unerwarteten Tod ausgesucht denn
dieser 30 Juli ist der letzte Tag seiner
alten Lebensversicherung und der erste
Tag einer neuen und so kassiert bellt
die Prämien aus beiden polisen ja
wirklich ein bemerkenswerter Zufall
einen Tag vorher oder einen Tag später
hätte es nur eine Auszahlung gegeben das
wirft schon die Frage auf wie unerwartet
dieser Todesfall für Bell wirklich kam
und ob da vielleicht nicht nur der
Zufall die ihr Hand im Spiel hatte ja
zumal es Indizien gibt die mal wieder
auf eine Vergiftung Hinweisen eine
Vergiftung mit Strich nie der Hausarzt
diagnostiziert aber aufgrund einer
Vorerkrankung von mazuren von eine
natürliche Todesursache vom Geld der
Versicherung kauft Bell eine
Schweinefarm in Indianer klar der
logische nächste Schritt nach einem
Süßwarenladen hätte ich wahrscheinlich
genauso gemacht oder man könnte es auch
als eine Rückkehr zu ihren Wurzeln sehen
sie stammt aus einer Bauernfamilie hat
in ihrer Jugenddorf Farmen hart
gearbeitet um das Geld für die Überfahrt
nach Amerika zu verdienen und wie man
Schweine zerlegt hat sie spätestens in
ihrer Zeit als Metzgerin gelernt
im april 1902 heiratet sie erneut einen
Mann namens Peter gannes der ebenfalls
aus Norwegen stammt und Schlachter ist
das passt doch gut leider wehrt das
Glück nur kurz peter hat eine kleine
Tochter mit in die Ehe gebracht sie
stirbt nur eine Woche nach der Hochzeit
einen plötzlichen Kindstod als Bell mit
ihr allein im Haus ist und im Dezember
fällt Peter ein Fleischwolf auf den Kopf
und spaltet ihn den Schädel okay
scheinen Menge tragische Zufälle zu sein
klingt schon bisschen komisch angeblich
ist das Teil aus dem wackeligen Regal
gefallen die ganze Sache kommt
jedenfalls einigen Leuten ziemlich
verdächtig vor der Gerichtsmediziner
beschreibt den Vorfall als ein wenig
seltsam entscheidet aber auf Unfall und
die Versicherung zahlt denn natürlich
ist Peter gut versichert aber da ist
auch noch Jenny Olsen eine Pflegetochter
von Bell
Schulkameradinnen erzählt sie meine Mama
hat meinen Papa umgebracht sie hat ihn
mit einem Fleischerei geschlagen und er
ist gestorben erzähl es keiner Menschen
Seele wenig später geht Jenny nach
Kalifornien aufs Internat das zumindest
erzählt Belle wenn sie gefragt wird
warum Jenny plötzlich weg sein
Spoiler Jenny geht natürlich nicht aufs
Internat und befindet sich auch nicht in
Kalifornien ihr Schicksal wird sich aber
erst vier Jahre später aufklären
1905 gibt Bell ihre erste Anzeige in
mehreren norwegensprachigen Zeitungen
auf persönlich hübsche Witwe die eine
große Farm in einem der schönsten
Bezirke von lapport County Indiana
besitzt wünscht sich die Bekanntschaft
eines Herrn zu machen der ebenso gut
ausgestattet ist mit der Aussicht seinen
Vermögen zu vereinen ah ich finde das
klingt irgendwie sehr romantisch ich
glaube es hat auch geholfen dass es eine
reine Textanzeige also eine Anzeige ohne
Foto war das war gemeinko ja okay
entschuldigung das war nicht wirklich
nett von mir aber ich habe Fotos von ihr
gesehen und ja es geht jetzt ja gar
nicht darum ob sie hübsch ist oder nicht
aber ich sag mal so man denkt
unwillkürlich dass diese Frau einem eher
ja eine mausschelle als einen Kuss geben
möchte und dass diese mausschelle
verdammt weh tun würde also sie ist eher
ja einschüchternd als anziehen
verstehe aber die Anzeige funktioniert
jedenfalls ja auf jeden Fall eine ganze
Reihe Männer antworten auf diese und
spätere anzeigen und besuchen die Witwe
und sie alle bringen Bargeld mit oft
Tausende von Dollar sie hat die Männer
nach einigen Wochen oder Monaten Brief
Bekanntschaft aufgefordert quasi direkt
zu ihr zu ziehen einem Herrn namens
Andrew hatelyn schreibt sie 1907 keine
Frau auf der Welt ist glücklicher als
ich es bin ich weiß dass du jetzt zu mir
kommst und mir gehören wirst ich kann
aus deinen Briefen erkennen dass du der
Mann bist den ich will dich mag ich
lieber als jeden anderen auf der Welt
das weiß ich du der süßeste Mann auf der
ganzen Welt wir werden ganz allein
miteinander sein kannst du dir etwas
Schöneres vorstellen ich denke ständig
an dich wenn ich deinen Namen mit der
Melodie eines alten liebesliedes singe
ist das wunderschöne Musik in meinen
Ohren mein Herz schlägt in wilder
Verzückung für dich ich liebe dich komm
und sei bereit für immer zu bleiben
[Musik]
und ich meine sie meint das vollkommen
ernst ich meine den letzten Satz also
komm und sei bereit für immer zu bleiben
denn viele die mit Taschen voller Geld
und Schmetterlingen im Bauch zur Farm
der Witwe kommen verlassen sie nie mehr
das erste Opfer dieser Serie ist 1905
ein gewisser Henry girlhold der auf der
Farm angekommen noch einen begeisterten
Brief an seine Familie schreibt bevor
niemand mehr etwas von ihm hört auf
Nachfragen seiner Verwandtschaft
antwortet Bell er sei nach Chicago
gegangen
1906 antwortet John Moe aus Minnesota
auf eine von Welt Anzeigen ein paar
Monate haben sich die beiden geschrieben
dann hebt er sein ganzes Geld ab gibt
sein altes Leben aufzieht zu ihr und
wart als bald nicht mehr gesehen einen
Zimmermann der gelegentlich im Haus
arbeitet fällt allerdings auf dass sein
Koffer zusammen mit dutzenden anderen
von unklarer Herkunft noch immer im Haus
war und es kommen immer mehr und mehr
Koffer dazu unter anderem von George
Berry
rund 1.500 Dollar aus Illinois anreiste
von Christian hilfken der seine Farm
verkaufte und sich mit 2000 Dollar auf
den Weg nach laport machte von Emil tell
der ebenfalls 2000 Dollar mitbrachte und
von Ole butzberg der 1000 Dollar dabei
hatte keiner von ihnen wird je wieder
lebend gesehen und dann kommt ihr die
Liebe in die Quere na gut Liebe ist bei
Bell vielleicht ein allzu großes Wort
sagen wir eine Mischung aus Affäre und
Komplizenschaft naja für Ray Lancer ist
es wohl lieber er kommt als Arbeiter auf
Base fahren teilt bald ihr Bett und
verliebt sich Hals über Kopf in sie er
weiß von den Männern die kommen und nie
wieder gehen wahrscheinlich ist er sogar
in das Business involviert doch
irgendwann macht ihn die Eifersucht
rasend die Eifersucht auf diese endlose
Reihe von immer neuen Männern die ihn
für eine Weile aus Base Bett vertreiben
bevor sie endlich und endgültig
verschwinden 1908 eskaliert die
Situation zwischen dem eifersüchtigen
Liebhaber und der mörderischen Witwe sie
kommt mir übrigens wirklich wenn je
länger ich mich in diesen Fall
hineinversetze vor auch ein bisschen wie
so eine so eine Spinne in ihrem Netz
aber auf jeden Fall feuert sie ihn und
noch von anderer Seite und ungemacht der
Bruder von Andrew hatte ihn erinnert
euch der süßeste Mann der Welt hat bellt
ihn in einem Brief genannt der Bruder
wird misstrauisch er hat einige dieser
Briefe gefunden und schreibt nun an Bell
wo sein Bruder denn abgeblieben sei wer
behauptet er habe sie wieder verlassen
der Bruder aber gibt sich damit nicht
zufrieden und kündigt einen Besuch bei
Bell an und der Sache auf den Grund zu
gehen kurz darauf im april 1908 noch
bevor der Bruder eintrifft rennt die
Farm von Bell garnissen nieder noch
während der Löscharbeiten wird klar dass
es sich um Brandstiftung gehandelt hat
erst einen Tag zuvor hat ihr Testament
gemacht und bei diesem Anlass über ihren
ehemaligen Geliebten gesagt dieser Mann
ist hinter mir her ich fürchte er wird
eines dieser Nächte mein Haus
niederbrennen der Verdacht fällt also
sofort auf Rey Lam 4 er wird verhaftet
wegen Brandstiftung und Mord denn in den
Trümmern der Farm macht die Polizei eine
grausige Entdeckung sie findet die
kopflose Leiche einer Frau mutmaßlich
belganes und die Leichen von drei
Kindern Bells Kindern aber das ist nur
der Anfang als der Sheriff und ein
Dutzend weitere Männer die Trümmer den
Schweinestall und die Farm genauer
Untersuchung wird das ganze Ausmaß des
Grauens deutlich sie finden die Leichen
von George Berry Christian hillcon Emil
tell ohne butzberg Andrea John Muh Olaf
Lindt Bloom Henry girlt Olaf Sven erot
und einigen weiteren Männern die nie
identifiziert werden in einem Bericht
ist von elf Leinensäcken die Rede die
von den Schultern abwärts abgehackte
Arme und Massen von menschlichen Knochen
enthielten die in loses Fleisch
gewickelt waren das wie Gelee tropfte
boah ein anderer Bericht spricht von
einem Durcheinander von verfaulten
Körperteilen nackte in Sackleinen
eingewickelte Tausi Köpfe Arme und Beine
die verstreut herumlagen und sie finden
nicht nur die Männer sie finden auch die
Leiche von Jenny Olsen die Jahre zuvor
angeblich auf einen Internat in
Kalifornien gegangen war und die Körper
zweier weiterer Kinder die nie
identifiziert werden in der Haft erzählt
einfach sind die ganze Geschichte oder
zumindest seine Version und umstritten
ist zumindest der Teil belgernis lockte
die Männer mit ihren Heiratsanzeigen und
verführerischen Briefen auf die Farm
vergiftete sie mit strichnien zerhackte
sie das hatte sie ja gelernt und vergrub
dann die zerstückelten Leichen und dann
und das ist der Teil der nie wirklich
bestätigt wurde wird ihr aufgrund der
Nachforschung des Bruders von Andrew
hedlin die ganze Sache zu heiß und sie
beschließt ihren eigenen Tod
vorzutäuschen beauftragt ihn die Farben
nie dazu brennen die kopflose Leiche
stamme von einer anderen Frau weil
selbst sei geflohen und es gibt Indizien
die für seine Version sprechen der Kopf
wird nie gefunden und die Frauenleiche
ist kürzer und leichter als begannes
nicht ganz klar ist von wem die
Frauenleiche stammen soll und wie er den
Tod der Kinder erklärt hat Belsy etwa
selbst ermordet naja es wäre vermutlich
nicht das erste mal wisst ihr noch zwei
ihrer Kinder starben mit Symptomen die
auch von einer Vergiftung hergerührt
haben könnten dann ist da die Tochter
ihres zweiten Mannes die kurz nach der
Hochzeit in ihrer Obhut den plötzlichen
Kindstod stirbt und natürlich
Pflegetochter Jenny deren Leiche Mann im
Schweinestall gefunden hat Leichen
Pflastern ihren Weg der Fall ist eine
nationale Sensation die Farm wird zur
Touristenattraktion und die Presse denkt
sich immer neue Namen für die Mörderin
aus Lady Blaubart schwarze Witwe oder
mein Favorit Hells Bell wie viele
Menschen wirklich auf ihr Gewissen gehen
ist nie ganz zu klären mindestens 20
möglicherweise 40 in den folgenden
Jahren gibt es immer wieder Sichtungen
von Herzberg aber keine davon kann
zweifelsfrei bestätigt werden raylem
fair wird im november 1908 wegen Mordes
und Brandstiftung vor Gericht gestellt
die Brandstiftung besteht er die Mord
Anklage muss man schließlich aus Mangel
an Beweisen fallen lassen
lammfair wird für die Brandstiftung zu
zwei Jahren Haft verurteilt angeblich
machte er später einem Pfarrer namens
[__] Lee gegenüber ein zweites
Geständnis Jahre später macht dieser
diese Beichte öffentlich um den Familien
der Opfer Frieden zu geben und um die
Spekulationen über das Weiterleben der
Schwarzen Witwe zu beenden ein Zitat
daraus in dem Geständnis sagte lämpfer
dass er Miss Garnis und die Kinder mit
einer Axt er schlagen die Leiche mit
Petroleum übergossen und sie und das
Haus in Brand gesetzt habe er nannte
Einzelheiten des Mordes und erzählte von
seiner Beteiligung an früheren morgen
auf der gangesarm wobei seine Aufgabe
gewöhnlich darin bestand die Leichen im
Garten zu vergraben wenn das so stimmt
wäre es natürlich eine finster Ironie
ermordet von einem Mann der auf ihrem
Mordopfer eifersüchtig war Alter was für
eine Geschichte
[Musik]
das war's für heute von uns und der
schwarzen wird wir haben eine Menge
gelesen unter anderem Artikel aus der
Süddeutschen Zeitung dem Stern der New
York Post und Beiträge auf weiß.com und
Orbits interesting.com und history die
feind.net wenn es euch gefallen hat
empfehlt uns weiter und Bewertet uns und
vor allem seid gerne auch beim nächsten
Mal wieder dabei euer Stefan und euer
Mirko